as Fred Hammond with dwell and praise
104.1 I'm still a studio with dr. Berg
now dr. Berg and his book talks about
the different body types and you said
the most common body type is the adrenal
gland body type tell us about the
characteristics of that what happens is
the adrenal glands on top of the kidney
there's to stress glands and when the
person experiences too much stress over
a period of time they don't take care of
themselves they start getting this high
level of this hormone called cortisol
that then puts the fat in the stomach so
really it's not the stress but the
hormone that's activated by it that will
put that fat there and I don't care how
many suits you do what diet you're on is
not coming off because it's not really a
lack of doing sit-ups it's it's that
cortisol hormone so they have there
they're always thinking about everything
24/7 they have a low tolerance to stress
they have memory problems going
downstairs like where am I going you
know they they lose that they eventually
apply blood pressure they have leave
pain especially getting up from a seated
position their legs are heavy yeah then
you a little sweet after dinner which is
a blood sugar issue they got acid reflux
they got bloating other than that
they're perfectly healthy
they have sleep things they do they
don't sleep and when the best sleep is a
half hour before the door alarm clock
goes off when they finally can get to
sleep but they're driving all day and
yeah it's it's so common yet people
think all these little symptoms are
separate problems but it's all this
coming from that one thing Wow Wow and
it's just really changing your eating
habit well dr. Berg is going to take
calls for anybody who have a question
for him so you could call us a studio
right now at 202 three eight three nine
seven seven seven
here's your LAN to Adams